if you had to pick
the worst ingredient
on the planet
what would you pick i'm talking about an
ingredient that's in a lot of foods not
some ban dangerous chemical but
some ingredient that is
very pervasive in our foods
what would you pick go ahead and type it
down in the comments section the
ingredient that i'm going to talk about
is much much higher on the glycemic
index
than glucose now what is the glycemic
index it is a scale that measures
how fast a carbohydrate
is absorbed and
spikes your blood sugar so at a hundred
you have glucose okay so that's pretty
high right now glucose
is a monosaccharide okay it's just one
sugar when you combine two different
sugars like glucose and fructose you get
sucrose that's table sugar okay and
because fructose is lower on the
glycemic index it's going to pull the
glycemic index down a bit to roughly
about 72. that's a disaccharide now
saccharide means sugar and die means two
and then glucose is a monosaccharide
it's just one sugar so the reason why
i'm talking about the disaccharide or
the monosaccharide is because this
ingredient is a polysaccharide which
means many different sugars that are
combined however this polysaccharide
is
a lot worse than glucose even though
it's a polysaccharide so it is the
ingredient that is the highest on the
glycine mechanics i don't know of any
other ingredient that's higher than this
thing i'm going to tell you and that
ingredient is
maltodextrin okay now
maltodextrin doesn't sound that bad like
malto well that sounds pretty natural
and dextrin it doesn't end with os like
all the sugars end with like glucose
fructose
so dextrin it doesn't sound like a sugar
but
maltodextrin
behaves like a sugar
but it's not classified as a sugar so
here's the problem when you read the
label okay if something has maltodextrin
in it it does not have to be classified
as a sugar okay it's classified under
the total carbohydrates so this can be
very misleading because you don't know
how much sugar that's in that product so
somehow manufacturing companies
came up with this loophole because they
know a lot of people are against this
added sugar
and so even on their website certain
chemical companies that make
maltodextrin
actually use it as a marketing thing
this is what it said on one of their
websites many soft drinks and other
flavored beverages contain maltodextrin
in their formulas so they can have a
lowered amount of sugar on the
nutritional facts
label wow that is a great marketing
strategy so the problem with
maltodextrin is that it behaves like
sugar yet it's not listed as sugar so
it's in a lot of different foods and
you're not being notified you're not
being aware of how much sugar you're
actually consuming now the reason why
maltodextrin is higher on the glycemic
index than glucose is because it has a
much faster absorption rate in your
stomach apparently the enzymes act on
this
man-made synthetic sugar-like
carbohydrate much faster than actual
glucose and so yes it is a man-made
synthetic sugar it's made with high
heats it's made with chemicals it's made
with acids so it's a highly processed
carbohydrate that is extremely
inexpensive you could get at a wholesale
cost
like
30 grams of bulk of dextrin
for less than a penny now you're
probably thinking well
i don't consume multiduction it's not in
any of my foods well i'm just going to
list some of the foods that it's in
it's in
supplements okay big time it's in even
the natural flavorings
i had to
really work hard to find a company
that flavored our some of our
nutritional products that did not
contain maltodextrin and unfortunately
those flavorings were a lot more
expensive than the ones that had the
maltodextrin when you buy herbal
formulas that are extracts like they'll
say i don't know ginkgo biloba or
turmeric and it says like ten to one or
five to one extract
usually they're using multiduction as a
drying
agent to turn it into a powder even
stevia when they turn into a powder many
times it's made with maltodextrin
so here you are trying to do low carb
when you're getting a lot of
carbohydrate but of course it's only
listed in the total carbohydrates not
the added sugars even powders that are
made from oil like nct oil and even like
certain fish oil powders okay now i have
a cod liver oil powder
that does not use maltodextrin it's the
only one out there that doesn't use it
and it took me a long time to find the
company that didn't use the maltodextrin
performance gels so let's say you're
going to do a long distance marathon
okay and you need that little gel pack
to give you that carbohydrate energy to
keep going well the first ingredient
maltodextrin so is an athlete i don't
think you want to take something
super high on the glycemic index to
start spiking your insulin then you have
the energy drinks okay the protein
powders the electrolyte powders many of
them have this added maltodextrin even
in the
vitamin forms as it forms like citrates
like potassium citrate or magnesium
citrate the infant formulas the infant
foods unfortunately have maltodextrin
the weight gain formulas a lot of times
the first ingredient is maltodextrin
but if you look at the label it's low in
sugars it's very high in carbohydrate
because they don't have to lift it as
sugars beer has multiple dextrin thus
the beer belly animal feeds have
multiple dextrin many keto products have
this hidden maltodextrin
which by the way i'm going to be putting
a list on my website very very soon and
i'm working very quickly on this so you
can have a list
of what foods have multiple dextrin and
what foods do not because sometimes they
sneak it in there a great majority of
the diet products out there the diet
powders the diet
protein bars are loaded with malt
production many of the soups that you
consume
desserts have maltodextrin ice creams
cereals snack products and even
intravenous nutrition the ivs that
they'll give people to rehydrate them
have multiple induction sauces
medications so maltodextrin is very
pervasive
in our food supply unfortunately it's
used to give the it's called the mouth
feel it gives a very smooth texture so
it makes it feel good in your mouth it's
also used as a volume enhancer
as a filler just to increase the volume
like i said before they use it as a
spray to dry certain things both oils
and proteins and and even nutrition
unfortunately it's been used as a fat
replacer
for certain diet foods because they want
it low fat right and so they can put
this in there because it actually gives
you the texture of fat
when it's really a carbohydrate but now
they're using maltodextrin
in a different form okay it's called
resistant
maltodextrin it's like a resistant
starch they change the chemistry
from this starch
to a fiber
however a lot of the research that has
been done on this
is been done from industry and i just
don't trust the results right now it's
kind of an experiment
there's a big difference between
consuming
synthetic man-made fiber
and fiber from
vegetables like celery or salad so now
you're going to see a lot of information
on these functional food fibers
that are now considered health foods and
they're in a lot of keto foods as corn
fiber
tapioca fiber and they're called
resistant maltodextrins so who knows if
they're gmo or not or if they have
traces of chemicals and there's not a
lot of information on the manufacturing
process personally i'm going to get my
fiber from actual vegetables and as i
was studying about this topic i found
maltodextrin is also classified as an
insecticide go figure and the other big
problem with mold production is it
depletes nutrition you see anytime you
have a carbohydrate or sugar and you
consume it without nutrients in order to
metabolize that carbohydrate it takes
nutrients b vitamins calcium potassium
things like that
and so when you're consuming a lot of
refined carbohydrate it's going to
deplete your reserve of nutrients so you
end up with less nutrition if you're
consuming these carbohydrates and all
this boils down to a much greater spike
in insulin which is behind so many
health problems so personally i'm going
to stay away from maltodextrin it's
really doing an experiment on people the
jury is still out on the resistance
starch time will tell
but it's very difficult if not
impossible to find an independent study
to truly evaluate
the so-called health benefits of mold
production now if you have not seen my
video
on the glycemic index
and something called the glycemic load
i put that video up right here
check it out
you